a murder-suicide investigation underway
in the Northwest Valley police were
called to a home near Gowan and Decatur
today after a family member found a
couple dead Mary Jane bellies alive near
that home with what that family member
heard in the middle of the night Mary
Jane
yeah Brian that family member heard two
loud bangs but thinking that it was just
the dogs making noise then this morning
that same family member checked on
others living in the home a man and a
woman he found the couple dead in the
master bedroom now we are awaiting the
identities of the couple and according
to Metro homicide Lieutenant Ray Spencer
the couple and the person who found them
were the only people living in the home
the deceased are both a male and a
female in their mid to early 50s
the preliminary examination of the crime
scene does indicate that the
that it was a murder-suicide I'm not
going to get into the specifics of what
has led up to that or who shot who
specifically but that's where we're at
this point in the investigation
Lieutenant Spencer says the man and a
woman were a married couple and all
three family members living in the house
were related a lot of Lieutenant Spencer
also adds if you're feeling any type of
stress or anxiety to reach out for help
he advises calling 2-1-1 to get in touch
with the Family Justice Resource Center
that can connect you to free counseling
reporting live here on Gallen and
Decatur Mary Jane Lee is alive local now